hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my Game of Thrones episode 6 video
there were some really big book changes
but some amazing reveals so just careful
for spoilers if you haven't seen the
episode yet the one big storyline that
they've circled back around to grab is
Jaime from book 4 but the other stuff
the cold hand stuff is a big change from
the books so I'll explain as we go along
but we got some more flashbacks was
actually surprised I wasn't expecting to
get so many so soon but the way Dan and
Dave explained it is they were basically
showing the entire history of Westeros
in images those are the flashes that
bran sinks so now he has to make sense
of that both do top 10 WTF and I'll
explain the book changes as we go along
so here we go
number 10 Mad King flashback burn them
all you see the Mad King working with
the pyromancers getting ready to douse
King's Landing and wildfire that was
right at the end of Robert's rebellion
as Ned Stark and the rest of the forces
were getting ready to charge into King's
Landing as Jaime's explained it in the
books he actually tried to help them get
into the city so that everything would
go off with minimal loss of life he
didn't want to see the mass genocide the
Mad King was planning on committing you
may have missed some of these images
they move by really fast there's a
shadow of a dragon flying over King's
Landing that was actually in the season
4 trailer so talk about foreshadowing
dragons coming back to Westeros there's
also a Lian stark scene promise me Ned
you see her hand in the pool of blood as
if she's just given birth or plus L
equals J just seating that a little bit
more we might get more of these so just
be sure to keep your eyes peeled
whatever brand goes into a vision just
because they'll be fluttering so fast
between scenes so the flashback itself
is pretty book accurate but the way
we're seeing it through bran is just way
past his book story but I'm assuming
that's how some of this will play out
it'll just be vastly more complex in the
books but number 9 they get saved by
what looks like cold hands but it ends
up being benjin start which is a big
change from the book so this is like the
biggest huge huge change from the books
in the episode george RR martin has been
very clear that Benjen stark is not cold
hands in the books the way he's
described in the show is having a really
raspy voice he's kind of halfway between
life and death like a hybrid white
Walker the way they did benjin's makeup
is pretty close to it it's just that
cold hands and the books doesn't talk as
much and he doesn't speak very clearly
like
so when you talk about Benjen being cold
hands just make sure to specify that
you're talking about the TV shows
version of cold hands but we'll circle
back around and grab him in a second
because there was a lot of talk of
hybrids and brand now being kind of a
hybrid which is kind of another book
change but moving on to the number 8 WTF
welcome back to horn Hill never thought
I'd come back here Samwell has to
introduce Gilly to his family in the
most British Game of Thrones scene that
I've ever seen next to Monty Python
Dothraki from earlier this season then
sitting here this awkward dinner comedy
here it's just the most British thing
that I've ever seen on the TV show it's
so hilarious Gilly is amazing but
clearly you see where this is going
samwell's father is another version of
Tywin Lannister just the biggest [ __ ]
ever we get a shout-out to Greatjon
umber he points out hearts bein his
family's Valyrian sword and just walks
all over Samwell til they find out that
she's a wildling and it just goes to
[ __ ] so Sam was like peace we're outta
here I'm gonna borrow this sword
I'm sure he'll totally bring it back
when he's done with it but the thing
about Sam wills father I know he seems
like the biggest [ __ ] in the world
but he was one of the greatest generals
of Robert's rebellion he fought for the
Mad King though remember back to Season
5 there was a scene where Stannis is
talking to Samwell
complimenting his father he was
basically telling Samwell that he
respected his father for being such an
amazing general even though they fought
against each other on different sides of
the war but if you thought Tywin
Lannister was mean this is taking it to
a whole new level which is why it was so
fun that we got to see him get killed on
the [ __ ] with the play and Arya story
line number 7 WCF Arya cannot do the
deed she gets to watch the play this
part of the play she likes she didn't
get to watch Joffrey died so it's just
the most wonderful thing ever but she
starts to sympathize with the actress
playing Cersei the one she's supposed to
kill because she did the same thing that
Arya did she ran away and joined the
theatre troupe pretending to be all
these different people and that's what
Arya is doing right now so the way Dan
and Dave explain it the way the way this
is played Arya totally understands the
consequences of what she does when she
decides to take the contract and of
course the waif is there so number six
WTF the waif made a contract with jack
and Hagar that she would be able to kill
Arya if she failed the contract so much
of this play is narrating what's going
on in King's Landing
the young Sansa character
to kill the Queen so that she can play
the Queen I just I love the metaphor
there but the wave herself comes from a
similar background to Aria she's
originally from a noble family in
Westeros and it's not one of the great
houses like House Stark House Lannister
it's one of the smaller noble houses
which is why she looks like she comes
from Westeros she doesn't look like a
dothraki or one of the other ethnicities
you would typically see in the East but
Battle Royale
it's gonna be like the female version of
cleganebowl Ali vs. Foreman Rumble in
the canals it's gonna be so much fun
number five shocking twist Tommen
totally drunk the kool-aid for Margaery
so there's a bunch of people here doing
things thinking that it's the only way
to help the people they love so it seems
like Margaery has drunk in the kool-aid
but really I think she's just
play-acting really really well she's
really good at it to save Loras but
behind her back the high Sparrow has
twisted Tommen so he's like oh this is
the only way I have to do this to save
Margaery well if I have to then I have
to so he's just showing what a weak
willed person he is he's just being
pulled from side to side Cersei was
influencing him now the high Sparrow is
influencing him and if you look here he
has new Kingsguard made up of the faith
militant there's actually an order of
faith Mills within the faith militant
called the warrior sons they're like the
higher noble born people that renounce
their titles and they're well enjoying
the faith militant so they become the
Knights so that's like Tommen's new
Kingsguard you can see their
breastplates have the seven pointed star
on them so you look at Jaime and you see
that his sigil is a little bit different
it's kind of a variation on the
Baratheon coat of arms with the antlers
so now the high Sparrow and the faith
militant have troops placed all around
Tommen which are essentially impervious
to influence so Cersei is not going to
be able to have sex with any of these
guys she's not gonna be able to buy them
off with Lannister gold they're beyond
influence so Tommen is almost
untouchable right now I know Kevan
Lannister is still the hand of the king
and seems like he's supporting it
I think he's not really happy about it
but I think he wants stability so he's
just willing to roll with it as long as
it doesn't go sideways but if you
weren't able to tell what Marjorie's
intentions were you can kind of see her
chuckling to herself when Jaime says
there's no way she's gonna do her
penance walk she muffles her laughter a
little bit I don't think she'd be
laughing if she actually believed
the words that she'd been saying this
whole time so Marjorie stoner a game
Lloris is the one that's in trouble he's
the one that's willing to just do
anything confess to anything to make it
and Tommen is kind of like the empty
vessel that you can just pour your own
thoughts in and he'll just say whatever
you want him to say a number for finally
circling back around to book Jaime we
get to book for Jaime plot line where
he's sent to Riverrun kicked out of the
Kingsguard which explains why we see him
and Lannister armor later but the
difference here is that at this point in
the books he's completely foregone
Cersei like he just doesn't care about
Cersei at all but on the TV show it
seems like he's more in love with her
than ever in the books that's not the
case they had sex for the last time over
Joffrey's dead body in the Sept remember
it was really controversial because
people were like is he raping her over
Joffrey's body what's going on here this
is very unsettling that was the last
time in the books that they had sex but
now we get to go to Riverrun so we get
to see Walder Frey number three WTF
Walder Frey is back in raking his men
over the coals because the blackfish has
kicked their ass and we get to see
Edmure Tully come back this is all
booked for stuff they still have Edmure
Tully captive he's gonna be held for
ransom
jamie has to get the blackfish out so if
you want to read along in the books you
can actually read this part it'll
probably be pretty close to the way it
plays out so prepare for Freight pies if
you guys know what that means if you
don't then I'll set you know for the
benefit of people that have read the
books please use spoiler tags in the
comments for freight pies but number
three they remind us about Circe's trial
don't worry I have the mountain so now
don't you just wonder what the high
Sparrow is gonna trot out like every
time someone's coming up against them he
has something in his back pocket
Jaime rides up the steps and says we'll
kill every last faith militant it takes
to get Queen Margaery out of here she's
not doing the penance walk oh there's no
penance walk but twist shocking twist
Tommen rolls out and he's drunk the
kool-aid so now we have this setup of
Cersei with the mountain like she just
feels completely invincible don't worry
I have the mountain so what is the twist
going to be what is the high Sparrow
gonna roll out you guys can let me know
in the comments if you actually think
they'll make cleganebowl a thing because
it actually does sound like we're gonna
see a version of that but number two
really big deal Daenerys mounts a much
larger drogon look how big mommy's
little
boys gotten since we've seen him last
and asks all the Dothraki to become her
blood riders blood of my blood that's
the title of the episode blood of my
blood is part of the oath that blood
riders take it basically means you
become the most elite of warriors kind
of like a Kingsguard that will follow
you into death if you die the people
that are your blood riders so I'll let
you guys argue in the comments who's
more hardcore blood writers or unsullied
because I cannot wait to see what grey
worm says when he sees all these blood
riders March up to think that they're
best friends with Daenerys oh you think
you're badass
I'm unsullied but the even bigger thing
here is that she said she's gonna go
back to marine and they'll sail to
Westeros so you can see how she's
shortening that timeline it's almost
like by the end of the season she'll be
on ships taking them over there but the
big one number one benjin Colton's
talks about bran working with the
three-eyed Raven he's been working with
the three-eyed Raven this whole time the
children of the forest helped him by
shoving a piece of dragon glass in his
chest don't you feel like that's gonna
be a thing again in the future they
mentioned it twice now in as many
episodes any time they mentioned
something more than once it feels like
setup for something even bigger later
but Dan and Dave the way they talked
about bran is a little bit different
from the books they talked about him
being a hybrid not entirely human I
think what they're talking about is him
being a green seer and he's always been
a green seer they just might be talking
about like the sum total of knowledge
that he's just absorbed from the
three-eyed Raven like he's a super mind
now that holds the entire history of
Westeros in his head whereas he did not
before so when you look at both sides of
the chessboard I would think of him more
as like the game master at least as
powerful if not more powerful than the
night's king in that until the White
Walkers marched south of the wall
Brien has more potential people to fight
for him but you have to remember that so
many people are gonna be killing each
other in the next couple of episodes
between Sansa's battle to retake
Winterfell and all the infighting
happening in King's Landing right now so
all that going on but the good thing is
that we have benjin now he's been
working with the three-eyed raven so
there's probably some knowledge that
he'll be able to help bran with make
sense of all these images that he's
looking at but here's my big question
for you guys let me know in the comments
what role do you think that benjin is
going to play now is he may be more of
an advisor because it seems like he
would be really good at training the
Nights Watch in the wild Lynx to fight
White Walkers
so whatever else he ends up doing he'll
probably be an advisor to
John snow into bran just to help them
plan actual battles against the White
Walkers because all of the fights that
we've seen against them so far had been
very one-sided
he's like the night's king just points
his finger in a direction in a sea of
ice zombies just wash over whatever it
is that he's trying to take so that is
not a battle that is a massacre benjin
will probably be able to help them form
a real battle plan but remember again
when you're talking about Benjen cold
hands in the comments just make sure to
specify you're talking about the TV
shows version of Colton's if you want to
talk about book Colton's we can also
theorize in the comments because it
seems like we're definitely gonna see
benjin again in the books too but
because he's not gonna be cold hands in
the books it means that he's gonna
appear some other way it'll probably be
another situation where he's serving the
three-eyed Raven
just not as cold hands but if you're not
gonna read the books don't worry about
it
benjin is back it's totally awesome
let's go back to Castle black party time
and I don't think we're gonna get a Jon
Snow benjin Brit Union at least for a
few more episodes because John is busy
marching around with Sansa trying to
build this army so I'm assuming he's
gonna see benjin after the Battle of the
bastards but you guys can let me know do
you think we're gonna get a benjin Jon
Snow reunion and do you think that it
will happen at Winterfell because that's
where it seems like this big Battle of
the bastards is gonna take place but why
you guys think about that reminder
there's a new round of the giveaway
that's going on now all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video I'm sure you'll
all be freaking out about Benjen cold
hand stuff but I'll announce the winner
when I post my Q&A video in a couple
days so leave all your questions in the
comments we have so much to talk about
now this is such a huge reveal even if
it is a change from the books it's still
huge while you guys wait for my next
video to post you can click here to
learn all about the brand stark
time-travel theory and you can click
here for my episode 5 video thank you so
much for watching everybody let's have
fun I'll see you guys tonight
you